it's half-life day a day we thought
would never come has come we have a new
half-life half-life Alex was announced
today I'm Curtin Avena and we are here
with Michael hi oh hi what's going on
like what do we know so far about this
new half-life game half-life Alex is av
our title so it's coming to PC based VR
so if you have oculus quest for PC link
if you have oculus rift if you have
valve index and if you have HTC vive
you'll be able to play half-life Alex so
this I could don't need a specific
headset to be able to play this which is
a huge relief because I was a little
stressed out I don't have the VR stuff
yeah yeah so I know I gotta get it but I
was like you know I don't have to well
you got until March 2020 because that's
when this game is going to launch and
it's it's a full story based game so
this isn't just a like quote-unquote
tech demo of something that you know
valve is working on it's this is a
full-fledged game this is a piece of the
half-life universe that's said to be
about a 15 hour story like what am i
standing like how are you doing that's
like what is the core like how are we
gonna move around because I know there's
VR games historically are really best in
small portions sure so how am I gonna be
playing like I can't imagine playing
halfway a game like half-life 2 standing
the whole time yeah you have different
options you'll have sitting and standing
there's also room scale so if you have
the space and you want to be walking
around interacting with your environment
in that way you'll have that option
there's also different types of movement
in case any type of movement gets you
sick in VR there's teleportation there's
a dashing style of movement and there's
also artificial locomotion where you
just push the joystick and your
character moves that one can mess some
people up so thankfully those are the
other options out there and also going
back where does this take place so like
we ended on a cliffhanger by the way so
yeah yeah we don't even have we still
don't have that conclusion so instead we
have like we're playing as Alex we know
that give it a name but where it does
this take place in the timeline of
half-life and half-life 2 1 & 2
it appears that this happens before the
events of half-life 2 because there are
a lot of shots in the trailer that kind
of give you the idea that you are Alex
in city city 17 stirring things up
beforehand because we see what looks to
be the Citadel being built still in
construction and there's a lot of
instances where alex is you know going
to places that we have seen but in
different contexts and I think that
there is a snippet at the at the end of
the trailer though half-life episode 2
spoilers are a 12 year old game but
towards the end of the trailer you hear
Eli door dad yeah I was about to say
someone's alive in this trailer by many
accounts we think of this as a prequel
but the end of episode 2 is we know Eli
dies and he says to Alex he says to Alex
close your eyes honey and you hear that
in there and I think of Oregon maybe he
also says that like you can only you can
prevent this Alex so in a way is it a
prequel but also maybe a time-traveling
sort of thing and that's not that's not
too crazy out of a picture for half-life
I mean they go into yeah they go wild
places with half-life so this might be a
way to kind of tell a little bit more
about Alex but also bring Eli back into
the story
as a halflife fam was this something you
were expecting like I mean we've been
waiting and waiting awaiting and it was
safe for me to assume like you know what
it's better if I just pretend it's not
gonna happen half life is dead and just
and then when you know the announcement
happens that I'll be like it'll be a
grand old surprise in which it was today
yeah but how do you feel about where
they're taking it now all these years
later I think it makes sense you know
valve has been going all-in on VR so it
makes sense that if they're gonna make a
huge push for VR you know bring out the
big guns bring out half life but it's
not just hey we're slapping on the half
life name you know it also makes sense
thematically for VR in the trailer
you'll see that she gets gravity gloves
you know zan gravity gloves away but
that makes me think about the different
things that half life Alex can do
because a lot of VR has to do with
interacting with your environment and
the different you know using objects to
in combat scenarios interacting with
your environment in different ways takes
what I have five two didn't like is now
bringing it to you like instead of
having a gravity gun like this item that
yes used to pick things up you are now
like exactly and all in it and the thing
about half-life is it always pushes the
medium in a certain direction and that's
what half-life 2 did with the gravity
gun was wild because you know I'm in
Ravenholm pulling saws out the wall and
then chopping zombies in half and that
is such a cool experience and picking up
barrels and throwing them at combine
that was such an integral part of
half-life 2's gameplay and if you're
gonna take that to the next step you
have to do that in VR where you actually
have you are the hands in that game and
you can see in the trailer that you know
there's a moment where Alex pulls in
like a grenade and then he throws it
back at that what she like when she the
part that got me was when like throwing
stuff off the shelf so like pick up a
shell and like put it in actually like
yeah [ __ ] it that was bad ass yeah and
then and so people might be hesitant of
like hey this is a VR game I'm not into
this but this is how you take what
half-life 2 did to the next level like I
said it's environmental interactivity
and if anyone's going to make a
full-fledged VR game right it's probably
valve and it's gonna be I think it's
going to be halfway alex based on and
the trailer is just a minute and a half
but there's so much to
and certainly that we're seeing in this
is that I mean the staples of half-life
are there like I know we've talked about
interacting with actual objects and
grabbing stuff and using as a weapon but
like headcrabs I can't imagine what it's
like in VR to have headcrabs going after
my head like I don't know you're gonna
have to prepare yourself for that one
but yeah like I said the things you want
from half-life are there including g-man
at the end of it he shows up he doesn't
say anything but just shows sweet
I really like this comes in you know one
here that like kind of crackly kind of
weird ass boys got a commanding presence
without saying anything that said
predictions what do you think is going
to happen in this do you think we're
gonna see a certain someone at the end
of it maybe a another g-man you know I'm
Sam
according maybe I don't know the guy I
don't know it depends on you know I'm
not exactly clear what the timeline is
for this quite yet I'm sure the people
are theorycrafting out there but I think
for uh as far as like what can happen in
this game I think you and I both agree
that you know maybe since this is a VR
game that has a lot to do with you know
using hands solving puzzles you don't
make this artifact know you're gonna
build dog oh yes that's right
that's weak you're gonna bail dog and
then you're gonna play artifact in VR
with dog you keep mentioning you keep
bringing that up
that smells even your twitter prediction
is gonna be 10 minutes and then you can
be playing an artifact with dog breasts
why now I don't think they got artifact
over there in city 17 but that would be
a really cool thing to kind of an
intimate moment maybe that you know dog
is kind of a quilting dog building that
being a lawman play solitaire dog
drinking games a dog but you can also
save you and you can also say you know
there's an ending shot to the trailer
before g-man there's this huge floating
ship or piece of construction though
that looks very ominous and I think that
that might have a lot of lorem
implications I'm not exactly sure what
this is but I'm sure it's related to
maybe the things that they're the
combine we're doing at Nova Prospekt and
going to unveil some more deeper lore
into the world of half-life and that's
the thing I was like almost kind of like
bummed out how good this game looked
because that means I have to like
to get a good way to play it I got to
get a good PC I have to get a VR headset
gotta invest money on telling me but
it's selling me and that's the thing
that's like kinda is giving that's like
I'm excited for it yeah I actually feel
for the first time enticed to really
give you our headset it could be the
nest this could be the next killer app
for VR games also the game is free or
you can get it for free sure if you
already own a valve index you will get
half-life Alex for free but if you don't
have one you can you can buy one and you
will get the game for free so that until
its release date you can go on to the
steam page and it'll be right there if
you bub whichever package you buy for
valve index the VR headset you will get
a five of free and if not then it's a
full-fledged $60 game so that's
everything we know so far about
half-life Alex thank you so much for
watching if you want to keep up to date
with other half-life stuff make sure to
come to GameSpot calm and stay tuned on
all that and jazz I'm Kurt this is
Michael thanks again
peace
you
[Music]